[Music]
[Applause]
here at the FTTH conference in Valencia
I'm joined by alexandre fonseca the CEO
of Altis in portugal alexandre thanks
for talking to us today now now Portugal
has a great reputation for really
leading the way to some extent with
fiber and with you guys it's not just
the big cities is it no it's true it's
true in fact we have announced back in
2015 our massive rollout of optical
fiber throughout the country that by
2020 we are estimating that we would
reach close to 100% of the population
and this plan is already well underway
and it's been successful we have just
crossed the 4 point 1 million homes fast
mark and in the beginning of 2018 so
it's going ok but it's true what you
said is that there's also a social
impact perspective in our rollout this
means that we have to decide a part of
our investment to dedicate in the
rollout of rural areas we do believe
that children in these rural areas have
the same right and the same
opportunities of children in the big
cities in the video urban areas and to
do that today it's fundamental for these
children to have access to the new era
the new generation of communication
devices so for us it's critical that we
also provide this ultra wideband
connectivity this fiber connectivity to
these very urban non urban areas and
rural areas and this is in fact a part
also of our strategy because we have
decided this year that we want to
continue to be the driving force of the
Portuguese economy but also in the
center of the social responsibility of
everything that goes on in the country
and this fiber rollout is also an
important part with this example that we
are providing we are now present in that
I would say most of the municipalities
in the country including the islands of
Madeira and Azores which are ultra
peripheral areas and we are deploying
optical fiber there as well that's
fantastic and as well as this commitment
to the installation and the services
there's a lot of innovation
there as well yes it is we have laid
down in Portugal in 2015 as soon as all
this acquired virtual Telecom we have
sat down in Portugal our research and
development facilities for the whole
group today not in Lisbon again in a
non-death big urban area in Aveiro which
is a city 300 kilometers north of Lisbon
we have set down our labs all these
slabs as they're called where 700
engineers are developing manufacturing
new solutions between them we can find
new optical fiber solutions so
innovation and this optical fiber
deployment in the country go
hand-in-hand because we do believe that
our ability to influence the technology
roadmap of the deployment is one of the
cornerstones of our success so
innovation is measured for us in the
involvement of these artists labs in the
optical fiber rollout but also its
measured in the new solutions that we
provide that can help this rollout in
the non rural areas that I've just
spoken to you before because sometimes
it's not easy for a massive rollout to
get to a city with 2,000 inhabitants or
1000 inhabitants and innovation is also
being able to run a profitable way to
continue to invest and to roll out fiber
on these small cities as well and in
turn I guess that leads to possibly new
services and solutions that are not
being able to be available before
absolutely I would highlight two
different perspectives one it's a retail
perspective our residential customers
perspective that we know for a fact that
when I would say why the broadband gets
to the home of the customers customers
start to change their usage patterns
they start to use more bandwidth and
with that they become I would say more
demanding in terms of services and
furthermore we know that customers don't
want anymore the Creta party the one
size fits all they want a tailor-made
solution and what we are doing is we are
changing a little bit the way we bundle
products to provide a residential
summers which nowadays is
one-size-fits-all let's be honest we are
changing this into a tailor-made
approach as well taking advantage of the
wider connectivity that they have at
home the second perspective is the
public services perspective it is very
important for a country like Portugal
which is one of the smallest countries
in Europe and with the lowest GDP s one
of the lowest GDP in Europe as well it's
fundamental for us that services public
services like education or health care
can also be modernized and digitalized
then to digitalize the healthcare or the
education system you need to have
connectivity in schools in health
centers in hospitals etc and this is
also a way that we are trying to change
the way we provide products and services
to these public services to allow them
to become digital and by doing this to
improve again the efficiency of our
economy either local either global well
it sounds like you're making major
progress thank you very much for sharing
that with us
thank you very much for digitation and
it's a pleasure to share our experiences
with you always thank you very much so
Altis Portugal using fibre and
innovation to bring brand new products
and services right across the country
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]